en este vídeo vamos a trabajar un
interesante problema de probabilidad que
nos va a permitir familiarizarnos más
con los temas en común
lo que nos pide es averiguar la
probabilidad de conseguir al menos
una cara
claro está al menos una cara al arrojar
una moneda verdad arrojamos una moneda
una determinada cantidad de veces vamos
a especificar lo es o al menos una cara
en tres tiros vamos así en tres tiros
es decir que arrojamos una moneda tres
veces al aire una misma moneda y tiene
que salir al menos una cara es decir que
vamos a tener este caso favorable que
las tres veces hagan caras o que salgan
dos veces caras y una vez hecho o que
salga una sola cara y dos sellos o así
sucesivamente distintos sucesos
todos esos van a ser favorables porque
nos piden al menos una cara al menos una
cara es decir que puede haber una o más
y esto también se puede ver de otra
forma el único caso que no va a ser
favorable déjenme terminar esta lista
entonces para poder hacerlo mejor sello
sello sello sello cara cara sello sello
cara sello cara sello cara a cara
tenemos acá en los ocho posibles eventos
es decir que salgan tres caras y así
sucesivamente en todos fíjense que el
único que no es favorable es el que
salgan los tres sellos es decir que ni
siquiera salió una cara tenemos por lo
tanto 8
voy a hacerlo acá tenemos
ocho posibles sucesos y siete favorables
sólo uno nos es desfavorable y porque lo
marco a este uno solo porque en este
caso estamos hablando de tres tiros es
decir que la lista de todas las de todos
los sucesos posibles la podemos hacer
sin mayores dificultades pero qué pasa
si estamos hablando por ejemplo de más
tiros la situación se complicaría veamos
entonces analizamos a este problema por
ahora de otra forma
supongamos que el primer tiro vamos a
tener entonces al arrojar el primer tiro
tenemos un medio de probabilidades de
que salga cara
mejor dicho tenemos
un medio de probabilidades de que salgas
ellos si analizamos buscar este suceso
que es el que nosotros intentamos evitar
cualquiera de nosotros nos va a ser
favorable entonces al buscar este evento
desfavorable vamos a poder encontrar el
resto de los otros para el primer tiro
la probabilidad de que se hace yo es de
un medio
para el segundo tiro exactamente igual
y para el tercer tiro exactamente igual
un medio
un medio por un medio por un medio es
igual a un octavo que es el único caso
desfavorable es decir si nosotros
hacemos
permítanme borrar acá
si nosotros hacemos la totalidad de los
casos
expresados por un 1 el lunes el entero
en la totalidad de los casos el 100 por
ciento menos el evento de que salgan 3
ellos
vamos a tener que hacer uno menos un
octavo y uno menos un octavo es
justamente siete octavos fíjense cómo
entonces analizamos el mismo problema de
distintos puntos de vista
consiguiendo un mismo resultado pero
ahora porque trabajo y vuelvo a lo que
les había remarcado antes porque trabajo
de esta forma y no de otra acá es más
simple porque tenemos sólo un evento
desfavorable antes había sido sencillo
hacer toda la lista pero fíjense qué
sucede si en vez de hablar de tres tiros
hablamos por ejemplo
de más de tres tiros hablamos de 10
tiros
supongamos 10 tiros tendríamos que hacer
una lista realmente extensa de todas las
posibilidades pero aún así sigue
habiendo sólo un evento desfavorable que
son la probabilidad de que salgan 10
sellos
10 ellos es decir que vamos a tener la
probabilidad de que sean 10 ellos va a
ser un medio por un medio por un medio
por un medio voy a seguir acá abajo
por un medio por un medio
por un medio y medio quedando cada vez
más chiquito por un medio voy a correr
acá un poco entonces tenemos
un medio de probabilidades de que salga
sello para el primer tiro un medio para
el segundo un medio para el tercero para
el cuarto para el quinto el sexto el
séptimo el octavo el noveno y el décimo
es decir que estamos frente a una
multiplicación de diez fracciones
iguales estamos entonces
frente a uno
me dio
a la 10
y fíjense esta curiosidad
estamos hablando de 10 tiros de 10
sellos y tenemos un exponente de 10 acá
esto entonces se puede resolver
fácilmente 1 sobre 2 a la 10 es igual
a 1 sobre 1024 es decir ya tenemos la
probabilidad del único evento
desfavorable
por lo tanto podríamos resolver
la probabilidad
de conseguir
al menos
una cara
en 10 tiros
haciendo
el total es decir 1 - la probabilidad de
que salgan 10 sellos
y esto va a ser igual a 1 - 1 sobre 1024
y esto es igual
1000 23 sobre 1024 que expresado en
porcentajes para que tengan una idea es
un porcentaje muy alto 99 9% digamos
entonces fíjense lo que yo les quería
remarcar desde un principio la
importancia de conocer el único evento
desfavorable en una probabilidad de
todos los sucesos el único desfavorable
para restar celo al entero al 1 y así
conseguir el porcentaje que se nos pide